ready to feast because one of las vegas
most popular buffets is coming back
thank you for sticking around with us
at 6 30 i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez caesar's palace's baccanell
buffet is reopening its doors in 13 days
and they're adding more plates to enjoy
too christian casadas has some of the
new changes that you can expect
well the buccaneer buffet here at
caesars palace is wrapping up
a 2.4 million dollar renovation for its
nine open
and interactive kitchens the buffet
closed down last march
but buffets recently were given the
green light to operate again
in addition to a new look the buffet
will continue to offer its popular items
like shrimp cocktail
crab legs and of course unique desserts
they've added 30 additional new dishes
which include grilled baby octopus with
chili jam
cheeseburger bao chipotle bourbon
barbecue oysters and duck carnita
quesadillas
i spoke to several visitors today and
they tell me with vaccinations underway
they feel more comfortable to revisit
these iconic eateries
i think coming to vegas that's one of
the things you want to do hit up the
buffets
because you have so many varieties of
all the different kinds of foods
it's just like everything else over the
top you know more than you can handle
and more plant-based and vegan items are
also being added to the menu
quinoa stuffed baby sweet potatoes with
fried kale
and tomato tartar well for the very
first time baking all buffet is going to
be
accepting reservations on opentable.com
so you better act fast
because they open on may 20th christian
casarez 8 news now